c'était il ya une semaine les ex
villenouvelle criaient à l'injustice
fiscale les élus voyait déjà le budget
de l'agglomération amputé de 13 à 16
millions d'euros
aujourd'hui nos élus sont soulagés
l'assemblée nationale a enterré cette
idée jeudi dernier une bouffée d'air
pour le président de saint quentin en
yvelines michel logique il était anormal
que on ne prennent pas en considération
notre origine historique c'est à dire
nous sommes issus d'une ville nouvelle
et donc à ce titre là nous avons
construit dans le nombre d'équipements
publics ce qui fait que notre communauté
d'agglomération aujourd'hui à une lourde
dette
mais la dette qui a été bien sûr générés
par tous ces aménagements
donc si nous bénéficions depuis quelques
années de cette situation il était
anormal que à l'occasion du vote de la
loi de finances demande mans soit votée
en catimini
[Musique]
juste avant noël c'était l'interview du
président de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
michèle losier et du côté des élus de
gauche de saint quentin en yvelines
il se félicite aussi de ce changement
pour la première secrétaire fédérale du
parti socialiste yves hinse sandrine
grand gang des interpellations de benoît
hamon député des yvelines et des quatre
maires de gauche de l'agglomération ont
permis d'accélérer le dossier